Game of Thrones fans witnessed the death
of cold Drogo long ago when the powerful
warlord perished at the hands of his
then wife Daenerys Targaryen it was
tough to say goodbye to the Dothraki
warrior who proved himself to be
something of a sensitive man but not
engaged in acts of violence on the
battlefield few can forget how they felt
when they watched Danny's smother him
with a pillow to put him out of his
misery after he was poisoned by a
vengeful magician these episodes
premiered in 2011 which feels like a
lifetime ago
but Khal Drogo experienced something of
a second death when actor Jason Momoa
shaved off his signature beard for the
first time since 2012 Momoa who appeared
as kool Drogo on Game of Thrones for
only 10 episodes and still managed to
win the hearts of millions posted a
video of himself shearing off his famous
facial hair to his YouTube channel on
April 17th
Alton the open wilderness presumably on
location filming the June reboot the
actor took an electric clipper to his
beard with each chunk he shaved off the
actor bid farewell to a character he
played while rocking it
goodbye Drogo fire degree the actor
quickly revealed that he wasn't getting
rid of his whiskers all willy-nilly
rather Momoa stripped his strapping face
of all its hair and stubble for a good
cause to increase awareness about the
importance of reducing plastic to help
preserve the environment I just want to
do this to bring awareness the plastics
are killing our planet
and I figure out a solution Momoa
continued detailing that is launching a
line of aluminium or as Americans say
aluminum cans of water that are
completely recyclable according to the
actor about 75% of aluminum has ever
been used - still in circulation today
and this 100% recyclable so you drink
the can and in about 60 days it'll be
back 100 percent as he puts it just
water but I feel good about it
as Momoa cleaned up the last remaining
hairs on his face he gave a little shout
out to his superhero character to drive
his point home saying Aquaman's trying
to do the best he can for my kids for
your kids for the world clean up the
oceans clean up the land and now
apparently so is Momoa a video was
momentous as Momoa buzzing off the beard
is had for the better part of a decade
was bound to garner a ton of attention
and they got people talking fans quickly
flocked to the comment section of the
video and to Twitter to react to be
Atlas Momoa many like Twitter user at
miss Donna Cook pointed out the
unfortunate truth that not only do we
live in a world where most people don't
recycle
but we now also live in a world where
Jason Momoa no longer has a beard she
wrote in a post well done guys first you
destroyed the planet and they destroyed
Jason Momoa was beard I don't know which
is worse
shame on you all she also appended the
hashtag bring back the beard judging by
the reactions to the YouTube video which
has drawn over 4 million views after
only a couple of days people think Momoa
still looks great with or without the
beard many were more blown away by the
actors activism than by his new look as
one fan wrote on Twitter with and
without beard he's still attractive
Jason Momoa shaving his beard for a good
cause spreading awareness and the
solution at the end of the day hair
grows back in a way it's just as
infinitely recyclable a resource as
aluminum so Momoa might again sport the
lush cold Rogo beard his fans clearly
love one day whether or not that happens
though one thing's for certain Momoa
will continue trying to save the planet
and that's arguably more badass than
anything Drogo did on Game of Thrones
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]